i attempted to paint my nails for the
first time since i was in middle school
usually i go to get a manicure at a
professional salon and they do it for
you and it looks so easy they just
and it's magically just done so that's
before the other day this is not a
sponsored video i just happened to see
this and i i bought it so not sponsored
video it's a chalkboard manicure it's
kind of like a matte finish stuff so i
said hey you know what just you're
artistic you're creative you can do this
just gave myself a pep talk right there
in the middle of the store so i came
home and filmed it i haven't actually
looked at the footage so hopefully this
even works out at all and let me tell
you what it kind of ended up looking
like a three-year-old blindfolded
did them i tried my best i just looked
up right now it looks like i'm naked but
i'm not i'm wearing a tank top so shut
your mouth tank top not naked i've got
tint hey
let me know what you guys think of my
attempt at doing a chalkboard manicure
and if you
uh are better at doing your nails than i
am feel free to leave me a video as a
video response so i can feel bad about
myself thanks for watching this is the
end of the video
what is it tank top
i'm probably going to put that at the
end just because i want to make a gif
out of it so yeah that's why
that's at the end